[Music]
now we go to amy who joins us in denver
colorado amy how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call
i'm looking i think for some outside
guidance
first i have to say i'm blessed for the
life i have i'm grateful
um i'm blessed though and i'm uh
discontented with it and uh i think my
question is ultimately how do i advocate
my for myself or sell myself or get a
seat at the table
i left three years ago i left a a
private sector job management managing
people managing operations a six-figure
job lots of hours pretty miserable
to i just had an opportunity to leave it
and i wanted i know i needed to be part
of
community that's the only thing i come
up with i want to be more involved with
community
i took a job you know cut my salary in
half and i took a job and it's great i
love working 40 hours
it's really nice
you know but i'm not stimulated i'm not
challenged i'm it's it's nothing out of
it and uh and i
kind of conceded okay if i want to get
back into challenging that means i'd
have to manage people which i'm not
quite sure i'm the right person for
i've taken all kinds of steps to
you know professionally network and do
presentations and do stuff outside of my
comfort zone um
and i'm in a different sector and so i'm
you know obviously i'm young in the
sector and i'm looked at as as pretty
much zero experience
amy so are you telling me you have no
idea you have no direction there's not
something that you'd want to try
professionally if lack of experience
lack of connections lack of fear lack of
doubt if i could just wipe it away
you're telling me you have no idea you
haven't wondered about a type of work
oh no i have that's what i want to hear
i want to hear what would you do
tomorrow this is a simple question and i
need you to suspend your brain here this
is a heart only answer what would you
try tomorrow you'd have to commit the
rest of your work life to it but you'd
try it if you knew you couldn't fail
what work would you do
it's it's kind of it's a motivational
thing coaching coaching who
you know the answer don't even hey i saw
what just happened by the way i do this
every day on the ken coleman show so now
you're trapped all right and this is a
good thing
you know the answer who do you want to
coach
it's women and i laugh because uh it's
just in the last five years women have
become a part of my life and i i've
always been around men so it's just
funny okay so who so i understand you
want to coach women but what challenge
do they have that you want to help them
solve
to overcome obstacles that they can't do
it
can't do what
well there's different things like i've
done some um
some physical fitness type stuff and
i've seen women come in it's their first
time and they're they're not made
through and i run next to them and do
push-ups with them
i just took a bunch of ladies out on a
mud run who's never done it before um
i've consulted with fundraisers who
don't know how to fundraise and i'm not
a fundraiser right right
you know what you are amy you're a you
you personally are a go-getter and i
think if we were to just pick one word
and i don't want you to after this phone
call lock into this word and make it
your personal brand but i want you to
just open your mind to this
um but i think you are a coach
and when you say you want to coach it's
because i think you are a coach like i
think that's just who you are you kind
of just bounce into people and when you
see them down or a little bit different
you know and they're not where they're
supposed to be you can see they don't
have their spark and you want to figure
out why and then help them get their
spark is that a fair
close analysis
yeah okay so here's the deal for today
let's just say you want to be a
performance coach i think you've got to
do some research on this and we got to
figure out how we transition i think
that's the biggest scariest part but you
could be a life coach i don't really
care what you label it but i think you
got to look at where am i going to
specialize excuse me where am i going to
specialize now you may offer a suite of
things maybe you offer some financial
coaching and some nutritional exercise
fitness coaching maybe it's more in the
career space i don't know but that's
your homework assignment you got to go
okay
one of the what are the biggest or
what's the list of of challenges your
word obstacles that women face that you
get the most juice
when you think about helping those women
climb that obstacle therein lies your
answer now we've got this day job
and so we've got to look at the
financial piece how we make the
transition so once you know what you
want to do you ask this in fact i'm
going to give you four qualifying
questions you got something to write
with
i'm ready great first thing is once we
figure out the type of coaching we want
to do we have to ask what do i need to
learn
okay this is the education question does
not mean a four-year degree necessarily
in fact in this case it's not it's some
certification is what we're looking at
so that's the education question what i
need to learn second question is what do
i need to do what's the experience
question what experience am i gonna need
to do to get to where i start getting
some people some women in and i coach
them leads to the third question what's
that gonna cost me okay that's the
financial question what's gonna cost to
get qualified how am i gonna have to
sacrifice some of my work time uh you
know that's what we're looking for
what's the financial cost uh that's the
economic question and the fourth one is
the expectation question how long is
this gonna take
now
when you get the answers to those four
questions amy guess what you've got
a plan
and you're going to walk into it you're
not going to jump you're not going to
leap and you're not going to put your
day job at risk so this is again most
likely a side hustle unless in denver
you know fairly good-sized metropolitan
area unless there's some type of
position like this uh at a corporation
that wants a performance coach and you
can help women there you know you just
gotta look everywhere uh but this is
this is the direction you gotta look and
i think if you do it you're gonna find
it
okay got it
yes thank you you bet thanks for the
call you know it's interesting rachel
when when
i get these calls of course every day on
the ken coleman show but when someone
tells me i just don't know i just don't
know i've never had somebody when you
dig and you push they go they don't know
what they're not what they what they
really mean is i'm not sure yeah there's
a difference between i don't know what i
want to do or i have no idea i'm
completely clueless ken
and i don't know how to get there the
first one's not true the second one
very understandable how do i get there
there's fear there's doubt this is a
woman who's been very successful made
really good money six figures and just
walked away because she was in a
leadership position and i admire her she
went i don't want to lead people yeah
probably drains her
that and working 80 hours a week too
she's like man you know i want a
different yeah i want a different scope
of life yeah and i think it's amazing
i'm like and more
of this i could be wrong maybe it's just
my stage of life but amy what she
describes though
of people going out
wanting to do something that fulfills
them but even in that space of just
helping people
like seeing i see that more and more and
more and more people are willing to pay
someone to help them with that where i
feel like
maybe 30 40 years ago it was like well
just pull your you know i think you're
absolutely right just crunchy push
through push through but the coaching
aspect is beautiful because i think
people are willing
to learn and they're asking questions
and they want help and when amy someone
like her has
the answers and some of this experience
that she's learned she's like i can plug
in like i can help and that's that's
where i think the beauty is and and what
you do to ken is helping people find
that like what does that look like to be
able to help people and you're motivated
in it and
you're killing it financially what's
that unique role you know all of us have
it
whether it's a public role or a private
role whether it's i just like
fixing machines and you're in your happy
place when you're left alone to work and
fix a problem that's connected to an
engine or whatever and then there's the
person who wants to create art
you know what i mean and they and
they're kind of off in their own world
and they're creating or writers
or engineers or teachers
what it comes down to again is
what you heard from amy was
she's encountered some women there's
been some personal experiences that have
driven this purpose yeah she's kind of
going
i i've always had direction
and i don't like when i see my sisters
out here who don't have direction or
don't think they can do it i don't think
they can do it and she's the coach yeah
she's just the general coach so really
good stuff amy you're very inspiring
thank you so much for calling us you're
going to do great things to help women
in the denver area so go with everything
you've got